now is it true that daddy's to be into  sort of money-saving cost exercise in  the kitchen my dad and your kid yes  growing up Anakin pigs heads is it true  he cooked your pet rabbit  yay did I die jokingly said whose love  is going in the pot I went mine I came  on me skin dick Oh Johnny's done that's  not true is it  yes yeah thank you what what recipe to  use well funny cards look buddy I'm a  joiner and I made four heart  watches to breed rabbits for the pot one  of the children's shoulders and because  they were paid they were all giving them  names and saying you don't have farmers  going home and cows are your pets  hi uncle Blacky pleasure blanket was it  delicious  I was nice where would I got to go des  amis pets okay can I be on widget first  run all over him he murdered in it I can  see what you're against it for me okay  right Johnny wine yeah yeah you're gonna  meet your pack mission it's got a closed  on